[Music]
what Paul Ryan's departure really means
that's the focus of tonight's angle
people seem so surprised by speaker
Ryan's announcement today but I think it
all makes perfect sense after all John
Boehner is gone Eric Cantor is gone and
now Paul Ryan is out it should be said
up front I've known Paul Ryan for a long
time he is a stand-up person he is a man
of deep faith he is a man committed to
his family which he said was the reason
for his retirement now all three of our
kids are teenagers what I realize is if
I am here for one more term my kids will
only have ever known me as a weekend dad
I just can't let that happen
well on a personal level this makes
perfect sense remember Ryan accepted the
speakership with a lot of reluctance but
on a political level this reveals the
schism between the establishment wing of
the party and the conservative populist
Trump wing let's not forget how tortured
and outright critical times Ryan was of
Trump before and after his nomination
this is not conservatism what was
proposed yesterday is not what this
party stands for and more importantly
it's not what this country stands for
you have said throughout this process
that you will support the Republican
presidential nominee now you have a
presumptive nominee Donald Trump will
you support him well to be perfectly
candid with you Jake I'm just not ready
to do that at this point I'm not there
right now I regret those comments that
he made I don't think claiming a person
can't do the job because of their race
is sort of like the textbook definition
of a racist comment but after all that
Ryan and the president today what they
were able to forge a personal and a
working relationship but we talked about
quite awesome can you pick up the phone
and call them any day any time any time
yeah we talk all the time
and we talk about everything we talk
about policy we talk about families we
talk about our kids we talk about
everything and the speaker and the
president worked together on the tax cut
bill which will no doubt be the
highlight of their collaboration and
Paul Ryan was great on the life issue
and he empowered important house
investigations but on many other fronts
Ryan leaves the house with much
unfinished business although the house
did pass their own Obamacare repeal bill
both Ryan and McConnell together when
I'm unable to take it over the finish
line Senate passed nothing and his long
sought desire to reform entitlements
that big share of the federal budget
never went anywhere the true tragedy is
that Ryan swansong will be that
nightmarish 1.3 trillion dollar omnibus
spending bill it's expected to explode
the deficit to over 1 trillion dollars
by 2020 so for someone who had dedicated
a lot of his political life to fiscal
responsibility that is a tough legacy
let's face it
speaker Ryan was also uncomfortable with
President Trump's positions on
everything from tariffs to the wall to
foreign policy the two of them represent
opposing strains of conservatism in some
sense one the free trade more
interventionist establishment that's
Paul Ryan and the other a more American
first populism that's Trump the
speaker's departure is a clear sign in
my mind that Trump's vision not Ryan's
is the future of the party people
misread the investigation mania DAP
swirling around the White House as a
sign that the President's agenda is
unfocused unsteady maybe an unpopular
but in reality these investigations were
the insurance policy against the tide of
conservative populism that Trump
represented they needed to stop Trump
because why his vision is actually
pretty popular and it's actually working
Manufacturing's up and unemployment's
down china is back on its heels and
making trade concessions never thought
i'd see it
rocket man's ready to flush his nukes
unbelievable
regulations are being
Asch great for business even on issues
where Paul Ryan used to you know they
used to own these issues Trump is now in
his own way making a difference just
yesterday the President signed an
executive order pushing work
requirements hallelujah for those on
public assistance
Ryan's exit like flake and corkers
before him is but another indication
that the establishment that was unable
to beat Trump in 2016 it's frankly just
out of steam we all know the phrase if
you can't beat them join them in this
case it seems to be if you can't beat
them leave them and the establishment
may finally be seating the party to the
man who took it from them in the first
place and that's the angle